all right guys we're gonna try not to get kicked
out of here what is going on there citizens of
the reject Nation we just got done literally
like 10 minutes ago watching Spider-Man across
the spider-verse you guys could flip that
like button that'd be very much appreciated
we're gonna have to keep this really quick but
first you gotta work from our sponsor greetings
trekkies and Trek curious prepare for warp speed
because we're gonna Venture into the Star Trek
universe thanks to our sponsors Star Trek Fleet
command this free to play open world MMO lets you
take command of your very own star base on the
edge of the final frontier beam up and construct
fleets of your favorite starships and recruits
iconic officers to your crew as you chart a
course toward your expanding territory Vanquish
Rivals nine resources and uncover the secrets of
strange new worlds prepare to embark on a Voyage
to the mysterious Delta quadrant Uncharted space
is filled with Unthinkable dangers that will put
your fleet's abilities to the ultimate Kobayashi
Maru test so round up your crew and customize
your Fleet because there's no triple at all and
taking control of your own Starships so engage
with a strange new world to seek out new life
and civilizations and boldly go dominate the
Galaxy get ready to make it so with Star Trek
Fleet command's new Voyager Arc with over 20 fresh
missions game changing features and the return of
some beloved characters truly an experience to set
your tricoders worrying if you're ready to join
the millions of players already warping through
the Galaxy assembling their fleets and taking
part in spaceship battles Hit our link below
or scan the QR code on your screen to download
Star Trek Fleet command today it's a strap in
Starfleet Cadets and set your phasers to fun
all right so real quick the plot of this movie
trying to keep it to what the trailers have
shown us is to not spoil it miles he reunites with
Gwen and gets flung into the Multiverse he meets
a whole Squad of spider people who are basically
the Guardians of the Multiverse these Heroes they
start bumping heads on how to deal with this
new threat they're facing which is a fantastic
debate by the way I'm probably going to talk a lot
more on that later on in this video that creates
a massive conflict between miles and the other
spiders so with this whole journey they're upping
their animation style and action sequences but
really at its core it's a story about acceptance
and Miles having to redefine his whole idea of
what it means to be a hero he's got to dig deep
and figure out how to save the people he loves
most some serious soul-searching [__] right
here as bigger as this film is as higher Stakes as
this movie is it's also a much more personal more
intimate film about Miles Morales and especially
about Gwen Stacy arguably this is just equally
her movie as well in fact the prologue of this
film without giving anything away is very much
about her spot is as teased in the trailer is the
villain as funny as he is in this movie he also
becomes something that you can see is wow that is
one of the most threatening villains you have to
deal with John what did you think about it I'm
still piecing my brain together which is a good
thing this was spectacular in every sense of the
word but yeah coming out of the first movie which
is such a lovely you know imaginative sprawling
experience that also has this great Coming of Age
story inside I thought they just managed to build
on top of that and to keep the character heft the
actual emotional story super engaged while giving
you swaths of references and new universes and
new visual Styles and languages Like It Is A
Feast for the eyes and ears and everything in
between it's overwhelming but in a way that is
really satisfying and fun and begs you to come
back time and again I would imagine I mean it's
overwhelming in the same way how the first time
you watched into the spider-verse might have felt
overwhelming at first as well there were things
about it where I'm like okay is the pacing off a
tadpe here is this too much that's being thrown
at my face right now instantly follow the thought
of I bet on a re-watch it would not feel this way
whatsoever because into the spider-verse out
of the Spider-Man films it is my favorite of
the Spider-Man movies I want to watch it again
before I say a statement like this I think I
like this one more than the first one gotta keep
in mind this is also a part one of a you know of
a two-parter here for the sequels does it end on
a cliffhanger yes it ends on a cliffhanger and
man I didn't want it to end though I definitely
didn't want it I was like oh man you can feel
when it's about time you're like oh crap I forgot
there's supposed to be a part three to conclude
this story he's making a five hour movie go it's
a complete film still for a part two the it's been
a while since I've seen a movie that really ends
on such a cliffhanger where the story of this will
not entirely be complete until you watch the next
one yet it's still like remember how the Lord of
the Rings movies felt that way it has that effect
kind of like an Empire Strikes Back or two towers
the reason why it feels complete is because
they have such a personal tale here of what
Gwen Stacy has to go through and that's where so
much of the personal journey and what makes this
specific installment feel that much more complete
without giving it away you know same for miles but
he's got so much more of his character to tell
bigger Stakes of the film as it is and is more
bombastic and a crazy cacophony of events that
are taking place here it still had so many more
scenes as compared to the first one that felt
much slower more are intimate they're just like
scenes like dialogue character scenes that were
not about crazy Vivid animation just character
scenes with so many of the characters that had
so much dramatic heft heart and tension at times
especially with the parents there's some truly
Exquisite scenes with the parents that propelled
this movie forward and in fact so much of this
coming of age story is also about parenting
they're spliced throughout this whole movie that
also made this film feel that much more I don't
want to just say the word harrowing because I feel
like I abused that word sometimes but it does it
makes it feel that much more harrowing it is a
bit of a harrowing journey I mean the fate of the
Multiverse hangs on the balance for also what's
personally at stake here for these characters it's
so much darker than the first one it's a much
it's darker than a lot of the other Spider-Man
movies we've seen you know what it does it really
hones in on the hardships and themes that we know
of Spider-Man characters and make such a great
meta commentary on it but doesn't get lost in
the meta commentary on it it gets you invested in
the turbulent trials of what one has to endure on
such a grand yet small scale that's so impressive
how they do it yeah and it's also again super
Universal and intimate because even though these
are being applied to these science fiction Stakes
so much of what is happening is building off of
again the coming of age story that came before and
just the confronting of life as you come of age
as you become an adult as you become fully formed
there are going to be trials and tribulations that
you cannot avoid and sometimes life is going to
throw you a bad hand or some kind of thing that
you cannot negotiate or just go back and fix and
that is at the center of what's going on here so
there's like a harsh lesson being learned and I
think it's something too that's interesting to
split into two parts because it's something that
we all bargain with to one degree or another it
just happens to be applied to these you know comic
book style stakes and Aesthetics and the art style
too I mean as beautiful and Grand as it was the
first time around I thought they made that even
more expressive here so that the emotionality of
the scene work and even those scenes that
are just breathing and aren't so kinetic
have the bolstering of the art that feels very
alive and again like even though this is probably
all made on a computer it feels like somebody took
the time to draw it and really put that care into
everything and the array of other characters too
and and the little glimpses into their versions of
the trials and tribulations of a Spider-Man Spider
Woman whatever you know it all comes back to
something relatable and Universal even though yeah
it's so high concept yeah there's a lot of these
great dream like abstract Expressions that they'll
do that are just about the hardships and the
terror that's going on within like Miles Morales
especially in this movie sequences where it's
like this is just something that's taking place
within his mind it has a bit of that cerebral
effect of the horrors of the things you gotta face
within that are also manifesting itself externally
it's it's so much deeper than the first one and
but it's still really funny it's a really funny
movie at the same time I mean some characters
that have been teased within the trailers you
know like spider Punk uh he's hilarious rock
star character Anarchist like this 60s 70s type
of rock and roller anti-capitalism sjw yeah yeah
just the Locust guy look out yeah but he's still
so freaking awesome yeah so awesome commentary he
makes are made a lot of times for jokes it's never
like making a serious messenger point with him
implementing him here with his crazy Expressions
again with his animation style are awesome one
character I was surprised by as well I don't
know how to pronounce his name the Spider-Man
India character he was hilarious what a wonderful
addition to this whole universe and a beautiful
world of Mumbai whatever the combination of
Mumbai Brooklyn is yeah and then of course you got
Miguel O'Hara Spider-Man 299 what I loved about it
is in the trailers when you watch it you're like
okay is he gonna be a villain he does have this
I don't want to give it away because it's so
much more gray and that's one of the coolest
Parts about it is the film definitely has like
an a threatening quality about him yet I wouldn't
categorize him as a villain there's such a debate
at its core that was like kind of given away uh
there's so much more to it there's so much more
meat around it than what's in the trailers there
is a debate surrounding an inner conflict that
happens between him and uh miles that involves
you know what it really means to be a Spider-Man
and certain sacrifices one has to make and it is a
fantastic debate that this movie's having because
even I'm there and I'm rooting for miles at the
same time I'm in my the audience seat going is
Miles making the right choice yeah we would all
be in your shoes but also look at the big picture
I get that Miguel's a terrible communicator but
I guess he's just such an aggressive [__] at
the same time you're like but what if Miguel is
the one who is right about this right what if
he's the only one who's willing to go through
with what's right yeah yeah it does a great job
at painting that there's not as much ben Reilly
as I think some people might want in here
kind of like soften the blow a little bit
there Jessica Drew was another very fun welcome
addition who brings a lot of energy and commands
the screen whenever she's there the movie's more
suspenseful than the last one it's more intense
it's more complex and that complexity is such a
compliment to it because it easily could have been
over convoluted yet it doesn't go past that line
I feel like this movie is phenomenal I think it's
inspiring one of the best animated movies I've
ever seen yeah I mean is it leave you off on a
note that is as fun or hopeful like the first
movie while crazy is still simple compared to
what this is yeah but this one absolutely leaves
you wanting more right now and it leaves off in
a place where you go ah but then you immediately
feel that swell of having been through a cathartic
and Grand experience and yeah it leaves you with
tons to appreciate and anticipate all at the same
time again on my first few women there were parts
and specifically like the first 30 to 40 minutes
because it could be such like a kinetic ride and
then we got a really serious scene here and it's
slowing me down and I was like I don't know
if it's just because I'm coming off the high
of that kinetic scene that sometimes I was like
having a bit of a difficult time I wouldn't even
say difficult it was going to calibrate your
brain you do got to calibrate your mind and
hard at times to go okay now we're slowing down
yeah yeah absolutely but I wouldn't have it any
other way a perfect way to do a part two because
it takes the events of what happened in the first
one and this is the residual consequences carrying
over into here but still telling a different story
but carrying on the same story is the next
chapter of a life it's a strong ass film man
you're flawless I can't believe it was like 40
minutes and I'm like I can't believe they just
did it again like they did it again and better
like yeah it's rarely occasion that I come into
one of these without like worries that they're
gonna clear the bar but they just effortlessly
you know swept me off on a journey with this and
yeah this might be one of the greatest sequels
to one of the greatest comic book movies a
hundred thousand percent on Rotten Tomatoes
I see you guys did you see this movie what are
you most looking forward to if you haven't seen
it leave your thoughts down below what
do you hope to see in part three which
they I don't know if they've revealed the
title already but they reveal the title of
the third one at the end of this movie if
you didn't know the title already so yeah
uh anyway the title's like ah great title
exactly yeah leave your thoughts down below
thank you so much for being here we will
talk with you all soon thanks again guys